[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute
party-snacks für Silvester die natürlich
auch das ganze Jahr über zubereiten
können und zwar alles unter dem Motto
Pizza wir machen viel richtig coole
pizzasacks und dafür brauchen wir
natürlich ein Pizzateig und der geht
ganz ganz schnell und einfach ich starte
direkt ich gebe hier zuallererst mal
lauwarmes Wasser in meine Schüssel und
da gebe ich dann frische Hefe rein und
ein bisschen Zucker und verrührt das und
dann kommt natürlich darauf an was für
ein Mehl ihr verwendet ihr seht schon
hier ich habe Pizza Mehl und ähm ja dann
machen wir einfach unseren schnellen
Teig die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
findet ihr wie immer hier unten in der
Inbox
[Musik]
so jetzt erst kommt Salz mit dazu Salz
also niemals direkt zur Hefe geben und
dann verknete ich das mit den Händen
also ihr könnt auch statt das pizzamehls
aber das ist ein besonderes Mehl mit
hohen klebereigenschaften könnt ihr auch
ganz normales Weizenmehl Typ 405
verwenden es ginge sogar Dinkelmehl Typ
630 das schreibe ich euch am besten
alles in die Infobox damit es nicht too
much information ist auf jeden Fall
werde ich das jetzt hier mit den Händen
einfach zu einem geschmeidigen Teig
kneten und weil wir heute vier Rezepte
machen teile ich den Teig anschließend
durch drei so dass ich vier Tage gehabt
sagt man das so ja dreimal Teile habe
ich vier Teile mein Teig kommt jetzt auf
die Arbeitsfläche dann kann man einfach
besser kneten
[Musik]
beim Hefeteig ist es bei mir so dass ich
knete und dann muss ich mir bei diesem
Vorgang mindestens einmal die Hände
waschen damit die wieder schön glatt
sind und ich ein besseres Gefühl habe
für den Teig und das könnt ihr natürlich
auch mit einer Küchenmaschine machen
aber ich mache das auch mal ganz gerne
einfach mit der Hand weil so hat man
einfach ein besseres Gefühl dafür wann
der Teig fertig ist der sollte nicht mal
in den Händen kleben und der sollte
einfach schön geschmeidig sein und vom
Gefühl her wie ein Ohrläppchen sich
anfühlen ich sag das immer ganz gerne
aber das ist einfach der perfekte
Vergleich
[Musik]
so der Teig ist schön geschmeidig das
merkt man daran dass wir nicht anfasse
das nichts an den Fingern kleben bleibt
und einfach richtig schön glatt ist so
jetzt einmal wie gesagt durchteilen
einfach nach Augenmaß soll gar nicht so
perfekt sein
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch am besten ein
bisschen backtrennspray ich würde jetzt
nicht mit noch mehr Mehl arbeiten weil
während der Gehzeit arbeitet sich ja das
Mehl in den Teig und dann geht's am Ende
noch trockener kann das jetzt aber auch
noch mal zu einer Kugelform und dann
zugedeckt für 30 wenn ihr Zeit habt aber
auch gerne 45 Minuten lang gehen lassen
an einem warmen Ort am besten ohne
Durchzug
[Musik]
so wir machen jetzt schon mal die
pizzasoße denn die zieht sich durch fast
alle Rezepte also bei drei Rezepten wird
die pizzasoße benötigt dann nimmt er
einfach Tomaten aus der Dose die werden
ja erntefrisch konserviert es gibt aber
hier habe ich auch entdeckt Pizza Soße
da ist dann auch schon Salz und Oregano
mit drin aber trotzdem können wir die
noch so ein bisschen
verfeinern nach eigenem Geschmack denn
ich finde persönlich gehört zu einer
Pizza Soße auch immer frischer Basilikum
oder frisches Basilikum damit ich mir
mal unsicher und da gebe ich jetzt nicht
nur den Basilikum dazu sondern auch ein
bisschen Pfeffer Salz ist ja schon drin
daher lasse ich das jetzt erstmal und
ich finde auch zu tomatigen Sachen
gehört immer ein bisschen Zucker einfach
wie bei der Prise Salz bei süßen finde
ich gehört zu Tomate immer noch ein
bisschen Zucker und dann kann man am
Ende nach eigenem Geschmack noch mal mit
Salz abschmecken aber ich gehe jetzt
einfach mit dem Pürierstab rein und dann
ist die Pizza Soße fertig
[Musik]
wir machen als erstes Pizza Coins das
sind
[Musik]
pizzahörnchen so und dafür brauchen wir
einfach Pappe irgendwie alte Pappe ich
habe jetzt hier einfach so eine von von
der Verpackung was was ich mir jetzt aus
dem Store mitgenommen habe ihr könnt
aber auch
Cornflakes Verpackungen nehmen oder wenn
ihr Pappteller da habt funktioniert das
auch das war ungefähr jetzt habe ich
vergessen euch zu zeigen das war
ungefähr Hand groß also nicht zu groß
machen aber ihr seid da auch komplett
frei also ihr könnt die counts groß
machen ihr könnt so klein machen ich
finde so ist halt so die ideale Größe
und ähm das geht jetzt wieder
auseinander wenn ihr das nicht
zusammenhaltet das ist okay aber jetzt
kommt er sowieso noch Alufolie drumherum
und das hält das dann zusammen
so und dann einfach einwickeln in die
Alufolie und dann haben wir unsere
selbstgemachten Würfel
Hörnchenform also heute ist bei mir der
Wurm drin
[Musik]
der Teig ist übrigens auch aufgegangen
das heißt es geht direkt los
wir können direkt auf den Ofen auch
schon vorgeheizt auf 200 Grad Ober und
Unterhitze aber macht euch keinen Stress
ich schreibe euch auch die genauen
Gradangaben immer unten in die Infobox
dann ist es total entspannt falls es
nicht gemerkt habt dieses Video entsteht
in Zusammenarbeit mit meinem lieblings
Supermarkt Kaufland und da findet ihr
einfach alles was ihr für dieses Rezept
braucht so jetzt habe ich hier einfach
so viele vorbereitet ich glaube auch gar
nicht alle es war so voll in meinem Flow
ich meine Silikonmatte ich hole meinen
ausrollstab und dann kann es losgehen
weil wir sollen das jetzt oder wir
möchten dass es einmal kreisrund
ausbreiten
[Musik]
der fühlt sich voll gut an der Teil so
den Teig habe ich jetzt ausgebreitet auf
ca 26 cm 6 mm dicke das muss so cool
dass ich überall die Angaben habe dann
könnt ihr euch das einfach zu Hause
besser vorstellen und jetzt nehme ich
mir hier jetzt nicht mit dem scharfen
Messer auf die Silikonmatte ich nehme
mir mein marzipanmesser und jetzt
einfach hier in der Mitte durch Teilen
hier noch mal und dann kriegen wir 4
Scones raus wichtig bevor ihr jetzt den
Teig um die vorbereitete Backform
wickelt einmal mit backtrennspray
benutzen wir wollen das ja auch dann
nachher schön wieder rausbekommen dann
nehme
und dann also spaßige Teil kommt jetzt
also spaßig ne aber da freue ich mich
schon die ganze Zeit drauf einfach so
den Teig drumherum zu wickeln
[Musik]
16 Minuten später die Coins sind jetzt
durchgebacken die sind außen relativ
knusprig das ist auch gut so und die
sind sehr heiß also wenn euch das zu
heiß ist nehmt euch da irgendwie noch
mal die Topflappen oder sowas und jetzt
gebe ich die einfach in so feuerfeste
Tassen denn die werden jetzt noch
gefüllt also die kommen jetzt noch mal
gleich in den Ofen damit der Käse
schmilz die nehme ich gleich raus die
Alufolie ist mir jetzt gerade noch zu
heiß also kurz auf die Seite legen oben
bleibt nämlich nur an und jetzt brauchen
wir erstmal ganz viel Käse wir brauchen
ja grundsätzlich viel Käse heute daher
fange ich jetzt einfach an den
kompletten Käse zu reiben weil das zieht
sich jetzt gleich auch auf die anderen
Rezepte ich nehme jetzt hier einfach
Gouda ihr könnt auch Emmentaler nehmen
oder einfach den Käse den ihr am
liebsten mögt denkt dran hier fettiger
der Käse desto besser schmilzt er und
dann könnt ihr euch eigentlich aussuchen
was noch so in eure Pizza Accounts
kommen bei mir ist es heute einfach Mais
ich glaube ich einfach Sucuk also
türkische Knoblauchwurst mit rein in
einem Oliven könnt ihr mit rein nehmen
eigentlich alles worauf wir Lust hat
Paprika Champignons eigentlich alles
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt ein bisschen was von
unserer Pizza Soße einmal in die
Hörnchen und dann könnt ihr das auch
ruhig am Rand so ein bisschen hochziehen
damit einfach überall der leckere
Geschmack dran kommt
dann befülle ich ich mache das immer
schichtweise also ich gebe Käse rein
Belag dann wieder Käse und dann einfach
so viel rein tun bis die Codes komplett
voll sind und dann wandern sie auch
schon wieder zurück in den Backofen so
lange bis der Käse goldbraun ist das
dauert zu 5 bis 8 Minuten maximal
[Musik]
so fertig sind die pizzakoons wollen wir
nämlich gut aus wie doof dass wir hier
immer noch Fotos und schöne ansehen
machen müssen ich würde am liebsten
sofort reinbeißen so das ist jetzt
fertig Endergebnis jetzt schon mein
absolutes Highlight ich finde das sieht
so lecker aus einfach vollkommen
randvoll mit Käse und leckeren Zutaten
aber wie gesagt ich muss noch ein
bisschen gedulden und wir gehen über zum
zweiten Rezept
[Musik]
Nummer zwei kennen und lieben wir alle
wir machen Pizzabrötchen und dazu ein
richtig leckeren Dip und für die
Pizzabrötchen nehme ich mal einfach
meinen aufgegangenen Pizzateig ich nehme
jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
Hartweizengrieß auf die Fläche und dann
gar nicht großartig kneten oder
irgendwas machen sondern einfach nur mit
einer Teigkarte einteilen aufs Backblech
geben wenn ihr mögt sie dann auch noch
mal zehn Minuten gehen und dann werden
sie bei 180°c
[Musik]
während die Pizzabrötchen gerade im
Backofen vor sich hin Backen mache ich
die leckeren Dip dafür benötigen wir
Creme fraiche ihr könntet alternativ
auch Schmand nehmen und ich gebe jetzt
nicht alles dazu ein Teil brauchen wir
nämlich noch für das nächste Rezept so
und da gebe ich Knoblauch es wird ein
Knoblauch Dip da Presse ich einmal
Knoblauch mit rein und dann eigentlich
nur noch Salz Pfeffer und italienische
Kräuter das Ganze gut verrühren und dann
ist auch schon fertig
[Musik]
so für das nächste Rezept das wäre
nämlich Pizza Brezeln brauchen wir
erstmal die Masse die wir in die Brezeln
füllen und dafür nehmen wir uns jetzt
den Rest vom Creme fraîche und da kommt
dann eigentlich nur noch Gewürz dazu ich
würze mit Salz und italienischen
Kräutern das passt halt immer und für
die Bindung gibt dir dann noch ein Ei
rein und dann könnt ihr auch eigentlich
alle Zutaten dazu geben die ihr möchtet
also stellt euch einfach vor womit ihr
am liebsten eure Pizza belegt und die
Zutaten gibt die dann einfach mit rein
und ich habe jetzt heute einfach grüne
und rote Paprika genommen
so es gibt aber noch ein bisschen
Pfeffer dazu für den Geschmack
so und dann einfach rote grüne Paprika
rein eigentlich könnte da auch wie
gesagt alles nehmen was ihr möchtet und
was nicht fehlen darf ganz viel Käse den
geriebenen Käse den wir uns vorbereitet
haben den gibt die ganz zum Schluss auch
mit dazu und dann zeige ich euch wie ihr
pizzabrizinformt
[Musik]
wir befüllen jetzt die Brezeln einmal
hier mit der leckeren käsepaprika Masse
ich sehe es jetzt schon vor mir ich
übertreibe wieder und es wird komplett
überlaufen ich finde immer mehr als mehr
vor allem bei Käse oder wie seht ihr das
ihr könnt mir gerne mal schreiben mit
was für eure Pizza am liebsten belegt
ich sag euch jetzt mal was und alle
Italiener versuchen mich dafür ich mag
Pizza mit Sauce Hollandaise und Hähnchen
und sogar Ananas noch mit dazu in der
Kombination echt das schmeckt so lecker
aber darüber darf man also über
Geschmack lässt sich ja nicht streiten
oder so sobald ich das denn hier alles
schön verteilt habe kommt das auch in
den Ofen ich schraube wieder die
Temperatur zu hoch auf 200 Grad Ober und
Unterhitze aber wie gesagt trage ich
euch alles ganz entspannt in die Infobox
und danach gehen wir auch schon über zum
vierten Rezept
[Musik]
natürlich dürfen jetzt Pizza Muffins
nicht fehlen ich finde das ist so also
es ist so ein Klassiker ist gerade
einfach dazu ich hatte mal so ähnliche
mit ähm Blätterteig gemacht aber ich
finde auch mit Pizzateig richtig lecker
dafür müssen wir den Teig diesmal aber
dünner ausrollen ich habe hier die
Abstandsringe mit 3 mm drauf für euch zu
Orientierung und jetzt möglichst
quadratisch oder rechteckig ausräumen
perfekt sein generell finde ich gerade
so bei herzhaften Rezepten darfst ruhig
mal ein bisschen rustikale Aussehen
genauso wie die Pizzabrötchen die sehen
ja auch bewusst einfach alle anders aus
was ich einfach so cool finde und hier
geht das gleiche ist da ruhig rustikal
aussehen
[Musik]
so das Muffinblech habe ich jetzt noch
mal mit ein bisschen backtrennspray
eingefettet damit wir die auch gleich
schön wieder rausbekommen und jetzt
einfach ungleichmäßig hier so am Rand
auch hochziehen und dann kommt wieder
das gleiche Prinzip hier brauchen wir
unsere Pizza Soße wieder und dann also
ich würde es persönlich so empfehlen
dass ihr erstmal so ein bisschen Käse
auf dem Boden gibt dann pizzasoße oben
drüber dann wieder Käse und dann den
Belag einfach damit der Boden euch jetzt
nicht durch weiß weil das ist ja schon
jetzt aktuell sehr dünner Teig und ähm
dann kann das halt passieren dass ich so
ein bisschen durchweicht und es muss ja
nicht sein hä 2 4 5 6 8 8
schon also ich muss sagen das wirkt
immer so wahnsinnig aufwendig aber wenn
man es dann macht und vor allem alles
aus so einem basic Teil das geht schon
recht schnell ne und dann hat man
einfach voll die Vielfalt für seine
Gäste dürfen übrigens weiß ich aktuell
noch gar nicht zu Silvester mache ich
würde gerne irgendwas cooles starten
aber andererseits wird es wieder einen
gemütlicher Filmabend haben
das cooles machen
ich lass mir was einfallen ich mache mit
selber Druck ich habe jetzt ein Video
gesagt ich will was cooles machen
[Musik]
so auch die Pizza Muffins sind jetzt
fertig und sagt mal ehrlich Leute sieht
das nicht einfach vielfältig lecker und
genial aus ich bin immer wieder
fasziniert von diesen einen Teig und
mehrere Fingerfood Ideen Rezepte da bin
ich immer wieder ein Fan von und jetzt
würde ich einfach mal sagen schweren
Herzens dann lasse ich euch jetzt auf
dem Video wünsche euch einen guten
Rutsch ins neue Jahr vor allem mit ganz
viel Gesundheit wie ist das jetzt auch
noch mal klar geworden das einfach
Gesundheit das aller aller Wichtigste
ist also bleibt gesund und ja ich hoffe
dass wir im nächsten Jahr auch ganz ganz
viele geniale Rezepte zusammen machen
und ihr einfach dabei bleibt also bis
dann tschüss eure Kiki
[Musik]